In 2020, the executives at Tesla all received
a base salary of $300,000.
Except for one executive.
Elon Musk received a big fat $0.
Getting paid nothing or next to nothing is
not new for a CEO.
Mark Zuckerberg’s salary for Facebook - now
Meta - in 2020 was $1.
However, their compensation plans are very
different.
Musk gets paid in Tesla shares ONLY if the
company does well.
Really well.
Elon Musk will only get paid if Tesla reaches
certain milestones.
These milestones are meant to incentivize
him to continue to lead Tesla through its
next phase of growth.
If Tesla achieves its goals, he gets a very
handsome sum.
But if the company fails, he gets nothing.
Here’s how his compensation plan agreed
to in 2018 works:
Tesla’s Board of Directors awarded Musk
the option to buy 101 million Tesla shares
at $70 each.
They’re separated into 12 tranches totaling
12% of the issued and outstanding shares at
the time of the agreement.
It might help to think of each tranche as
a treasure chest with 8 million shares inside.
Based on Tesla’s recent share price of $1,100,
the value of each tranche would be about $8.7
billion!
The key to opening each treasure chest depends
on whether Tesla can hit a certain market
capitalization - the value of a company within
ten years.
$100 billion for the first tranche to open
up then $150 billion, $200 billion, and so
on, all the way up to $650 billion.
To put things into perspective, the largest
automaker in the world at the time, Toyota,
had a market cap of around $191 billion.
When the Board came up with these numbers,
Tesla’s market value was only $59 billion.
So these goals were exceedingly difficult
if not impossible to achieve.
But Tesla did it, and in very short order.
Today, its market cap is well over $1 trillion
dollars.
Although the market cap conditions have been
met, Musk cannot access his big payday.
Turns out, there are even more roadblocks his way.
Tesla has to meet 12 of 16 additional conditions
outlined in the SEC filing related to revenue
and profitability.
The Board knew they set the bar extremely
high – admitting these would be “challenging
hurdles” to overcome.
But overcome it has.
Tesla has surpassed enough milestones for
Musk to unlock 7 of 12 tranches as of this
video, currently worth about $61 billion.
The company has to continue growing at a rapid
pace in order for Musk to get his hands on
them all.
Tesla’s growth so far has already been stunning.
It delivered 241,000 cars in the third quarter
of 2021- that’s 73% higher than the same
quarter the year before.
Tesla’s Chief Financial Officer, aka “Master
of Coin” Zachary Kirkhorn laid out the company’s
ambitious future plans in the third-quarter
earnings call.
You know our goal as a company here is to
grow on an average pace of 50% per year…that
remains the long-term goal of the company.
Overseeing these long-term goals will no doubt
be Musk.
The compensation agreement stipulates that
he HAS to remain CEO or he won’t get
to unlock all his stock options.
The only scenario in which he’d be able
to step down as CEO and still get the grants
is by serving as both Chief Product Officer
and Executive Chairman of Tesla.
This compensation plan is modeled off another
from 2012 that involved 10 ambitious goals.
So far, Tesla has hit nine out of 10 milestones
for that deal so he’s nearly been paid out
in full.
Musk is now a billionaire a few hundred times
over.
And could even become the world’s first
trillionaire according to investment firm
Morgan Stanley.
Some have criticized the world’s richest
man for how much money he makes.
Democratic senator Ron Wyden recently proposed
taxing the unrealized capital gains of the
uber-wealthy.
Currently, you only pay taxes when you sell
your shares.
Under this plan, billionaires would be taxed
if their assets have gained value even if
they haven’t sold them.
In response, Musk tweeted: Eventually, they
run out of other people’s money and then
they come for you.
As in, the average investor.
Around this time, the Tesla CEO asked his
63 million followers on Twitter whether he
should sell 10% of his Tesla stock.
He put it to a poll that favored selling which
is reportedly meant to help him pay his taxes
on the stock options granted to him in 2012.
If and when Tesla hits all of its goals which
would allow Musk to unlock all his options,
what will he do with all of that money?
He says half of his wealth is intended to
help with problems on Earth and half to build
a city on Mars.
His other company, SpaceX, is developing fully
reusable Starships to make the journey to
the red planet less expensive but the costs
will still be staggering.
Just like his rockets, he hopes Tesla continues
to soar to new heights, rewarding customers,
employees, and shareholders along the way.
And as he grows the Tesla pie - his slice
gets ever bigger, too
Tesla’s stock price has already gone up
nearly 13 times its value compared to the
start of 2020.
If you'd rather not buy into the bull market,
there’s another way to invest.
And that brings me to my sponsor Masterworks.
Historically, only the super, super rich have
been able to afford a Picasso or a Warhol.
That’s no longer the case.
Masterworks lets you invest in multi-million-dollar
paintings that have been securitized by the SEC.
You can buy shares in these artworks
similar to buying shares in Tesla or Amazon.
When Masterworks sells the art, you get your
portion of the proceeds - which worked out
to a 32% net return for those who invested
in Banksy's Mona Lisa.
And the art market shows no signs of slowing
down.
Contemporary art outpaced the S&P 500 by
174% in the last decade.
That's almost triple the appreciation of real
estate and gold during the same period according
to Citibank.
So it  wasn't surprising when I read in The Wall Street Journal
that “art is among the hottest markets on
earth right now”
It's grown 2700% in the last 20 years!
If you’d like to diversify your portfolio,
you can sign up for Masterworks with my custom
link in the description.
Thanks for watching.
For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.